[Música]
a mí siempre me interesó la ciencia y
cuando tuve que elegir una profesión
elegí ciencias meteorológicas o ciencias
de la atmósfera una profesión no tan
popular somos bastante pocos pero yo no
quería ser la chica del clima quería
dedicarme a la investigación e
investigar aquellos fenómenos extremos
aquellos fenómenos que ocurrían muy de
vez en cuando pero que tenían un gran
impacto olas de calor inundaciones
sequías
claro que ahora con el tema del cambio
climático esos fenómenos que eran
bastante raros y muy poco frecuentes se
han puesto nuestra normalidad
yo integro junto con otros científicos
una organización de naciones unidas que
se dedica a elaborar informes sobre el
estado el conocimiento del cambio
climático se llama el psc
estos informes se publican
periódicamente son la base de
negociación de los gobiernos porque los
gobiernos los avalan
estos informes contienen que sabemos del
cambio climático pasado que sabemos del
cambio climático que vendrá cuáles son
sus impactos pero fundamentalmente tiene
las soluciones
sabemos que a pesar de que hace más de
30 años se publica estos informes a
veces el cambio climático no le mueve un
pelo a nadie
entonces los científicos nos hacemos
ciertas críticas estaremos comunicando
mal el problema
cuando nosotros hablamos de cambio
climático es correcto porque se produce
un cambio en el clima pero a veces el
mensaje más claro es cuando hablamos de
calentamiento global
y cuando todos hablamos de calentamiento
global por ejemplo saben cuánto aumentó
la temperatura media global desde la era
preindustrial hasta el presente
un grado casi un grado parece
insignificante y cuántos cambios produjo
pero también sabemos que nos importa
saber qué va a pasar cuando aumente un
grado y medio cuando aumente dos grados
ese medio grado de diferencia parece
insignificante pero saben que los
impactos son exponenciales
a qué llamamos exponencial algo que
tiene una acción de 1 impactados de 24 4
16 16 256 ese es el concepto de
exponencial
y la diferencia entre que la temperatura
aumente un grado y medio y dos grados es
bastante relevante por ejemplo
si la temperatura aumentará un grado y
medio con respecto a la era
preindustrial la cantidad de olas de
calor extremas esas que ocurren una vez
cada cinco años
si esta fuera la población mundial
afectaría a las primeras cuatro hileras
en cambio si la temperatura aumentará
dos grados se veían afectadas las
primeras diez hileras de este auditorio
las olas de calor tienen un gran impacto
en la salud un gran impacto en la
mortalidad pensemos que en el año 2013
una ola de calor que sólo en francia
produjo 15.000 muertes
también sabemos que la diferencia entre
un grado y medio y dos grados impacta en
la pérdida de biodiversidad de muchas
especies se puede duplicar o triplicar
la pérdida de biodiversidad
también sabemos que los corales se van a
ver afectados
casi el 99%
la gran barrera de coral de australia o
pensemos en los corales del caribe
también sabemos que ese medio grado más
de aumento de temperatura va a producir
que el rendimiento de los cultivos
por ejemplo el maíz en zonas tropicales
se reduzca a la mitad o la pesca se
reduzca a la mitad con estos informes
algunos países proponen soluciones
otros países lo niegan por sus propios
intereses y otros países directamente
los ignoran nunca pensé que mi ciencia
tenía tanto que ver con las ciencias
diplomáticas
saben que hay una encuesta reciente
entre ciudadanos de eeuu que presenta lo
siguiente por suerte la mayoría de los
ciudadanos manifestaron que el cambio
climático los había impactado
regionalmente y hasta personalmente
pero otro resultado muy interesante es
que dependiendo de su partido político
si son republicanos aunque tengan mucho
conocimiento científico no creen que es
el hombre el causante del cambio
climático
en cambio si son demócratas cuanto más
conocimiento científico tiene más
certera es que el cambio climático es
producido por la acción del hombre otra
crítica que nos hacemos cuando
comunicamos el problema es que nosotros
comunicamos los resultados con un cierto
nivel de incertidumbre y a veces esa
incertidumbre se toman los negacionistas
pero saben que tenemos muchas certezas
sabemos que la temperatura va a seguir
aumentando si seguimos como estamos
sabemos cuánto y cómo sabemos que el
nivel del mar va a seguir creciendo y
podemos cuantificar cuántos millones de
personas que viven en las costas bajas
de la india por ejemplo sudeste asiático
en las islas van a tener que desplazarse
debido al aumento del nivel del mar
sabemos que si el río de la plata' va a
seguir aumentando y va a afectar las
inundaciones en barrios que están sobre
su costa por ejemplo
sabemos que los hielos se van a seguir
derritiendo tenemos muchas certezas pero
también tenemos certezas sobre las
soluciones las soluciones están y no se
necesita mucho mayor desarrollo
tecnológico las soluciones están
disponibles
concentrémonos en 3
el uso del plástico reducir el uso del
plástico sobre todo el de un solo uso
tiene un doble impacto positivo no solo
no produce contaminación en el medio
ambiente sino que también evitamos
utilizar más petróleo para fabricarlo
nuevamente
la forma en la que nos movilizamos
nosotros debiéramos poder movilizarnos
en medios de transporte público que
utilicen energías renovables
debemos tener presente esto para
reclamarle a nuestras autoridades
el tercero es la producción de todos los
elementos que utilizamos y compramos esa
producción debería atender y ser
regulada para utilizar energías
renovables
parece difícil parece imposible pero
saben que hay muchos ejemplos positivos
se acuerdan del agujero de ozono
el agujero de ozono el ozono es un gas
que cubre la tierra que es vital para
nuestras para nuestra vida es muy
importante la nuestra vida en los años
80 se descubrió que había empezado a una
disminución en la capa de ozono lo que
se llama agujero de ozono y también se
supo que era lo que ocasionaba es en ese
agujero de ozono eran ciertos gases que
el hombre fabricaba para otros usos que
eran los clorofluorocarbonos en mil 987
se firmó un protocolo en la ciudad de
montreal famoso protocolo de montreal
que determinó que todos los países del
mundo dejarán de fabricar
clorofluorocarbonos lo reemplazaron por
otros gases
lentamente se dejó de fabricar y ahí lo
son o se está recuperando
en la salud hay muchos ejemplos cuando
aparece el sida era una enfermedad
mortal hoy por suerte es crónica
la reciente imagen del agujero negro
cómo se logró se logró porque todos los
países
fueron hace un mismo objetivo compartir
su tecnología y sus conocimientos para
obtener una imagen
pero también tenemos ejemplos positivos
hoy en día en nuestra juventud
pensemos todos en creta esta estudiante
sueca que hace pocos meses empezó a esa
huelga y se sentó frente a su parlamento
con una pancarta que decía acción en
contra el cambio climático su
perseverancia en la lucha su mensaje tan
claro hizo que hoy haya más de un millón
y medio de estudiantes en todo el globo
replicando estas acciones
porque claro la información está la
información está pero quizás ustedes no
saben cómo los va a afectar directamente
en sus actividades o en sus lugares
donde están viviendo entonces la
información está pero no está
democráticamente distribuida quizás no
está transparentado saben que esta época
algunos geólogos
la llamaron antropoceno una nueva era
geológica desde la revolución industrial
hasta el presente una nueva era
geológica porque porque el hombre
interactúa tanto con la naturaleza que
produjo el cambio en el clima
entonces si el hombre es el que produjo
el cambio del clima el hombre es capaz
de reparar
cada acción cuenta
cada día cuenta cada grado de
temperatura cuenta gracias
[Música]